the u.s secretary of state came to
turkey for a brief
visit but he did not meet any government
leaders or politicians
instead he held talks with the head of
the orthodox church
on issues of religious freedom here in
the middle east
as the secretary of state of a great
country
as a united states has a very important
role and also we are very happy that in
his
wholeness was very happy to receive the
secretary
of state and to have
over an hour discussion exchange of
views
regarding questions of religious freedom
of fundamental rights of
safeguarding of the presence of
christians
in the middle east when it was announced
pompeo's trip will highlight religious
issues turkey's foreign ministry
responded with a written statement
saying the visit should instead focus on
enhancing cooperation on regional
and international issues between turkey
and the united states
and looking to the messages that he is
uh giving uh he is again
i'm quite sure that he's aiming to
strengthen his position with his water
base
uh back in the united states uh
presenting
his uh religious uh uh
sensitivities aiming to i think
post-trump era
uh my personal opinion was that turkish
state uh or the government should have
told him not to come
uh because this was not an official
visit and obviously
another personal visit last july when
the turkish government decided to
convert the hagia soviet museum back to
a mosque
pompeo urged ankara to continue to
maintain the building as a museum
the hagia sofia had been an important
church for hundreds of years before
being turned to a mosque
the turkish government dismissed those
concerns saying
it's an internal issue but the
economical patriarch has expressed his
sorrow about this decision
just ahead of his visit to istanbul
pompeo told the french press he agreed
with french president emmanuel macron
that turkey's recent actions have been
aggressive
he cited turkey's support for azerbaijan
in the nagorno-karabakh conflict with
armenia
as well as its military moves in libya
and the eastern mediterranean
pompeo's last official visit to the
turkish capital ankara was
late last year but he didn't go this
time while ankara sees this as a snub
his office explains it as a simple
scheduling issue
but pompey's earlier statements in
france that the u.s and europe
working together to counter turkey's
recent actions
may hint at a different reason cinema
solo
al jazeera istanbul